in 1905 the scientist fritz Sheldon made
one of the most important medical
discoveries of the century
he discovered the spiral kita paladar
the germ of syphilis syphilis the
greatest plague of modern times the
positive identification of the syphilis
germs was the first great step toward
the conquest of this devastating disease
as a Mason builds a house stone on stone
so science builds knowledge on knowledge
bit by bit only a year after the
discovery of the syphilis germs board a
and Wasserman developed and gave the
world the first blood tests for syphilis
syphilis could be diagnosed then four
years later in 1910 Paul early in his
606 experiment produced Salveson now
called arsphenamine this drug when
injected into the body kills the
syphilis germs air licks brilliant
success means of shouting war day and
wasserman syphilis could be cured but
medical science never satisfied marches
on treatment was further improved in
1922 lever DT found that bismuth aids in
the cure of syphilis hundreds of other
scientists added to medical knowledge
until today the diagnosis and treatment
of syphilis are efficient procedures
known to physicians everywhere
in spite of the fact that a cure for
syphilis has been known for 30 years
syphilis today is one of the most
prevalent of serious diseases a leading
cause of sickness and death
in America more than six million people
have syphilis one in 20 there are a
million new cases every year why
certainly it's terrible work can be seen
everywhere
syphilis strikes infants kills thousands
when it does not kill it may cause
blindness deafness insanity or deformity
in adult syphilis is a leading cause of
heart disease
it strikes men and women in the prime of
life makes many helpless invalid its
victims help fill the ever-expanding
institution for the insane it breaks up
home cause as many divorces wards
syphilis kills more than Wars
fires syphilis cost more than fires
floods or famine
why why when physicians everywhere can
diagnose and treat syphilis do we permit
this pale spiral germs to continuous
devastation the answer is ignorance
ignorance is the greatest ally of
syphilis the rich are penalized by lack
of knowledge as well as the poor both
suffer because they have not learned the
simple hopeful truth about syphilis that
it can be cured and it's spread can be
prevented fortunately times are changing
newspapers are aiding the campaign
against ignorance the radio is
presenting the facts to millions
literature is being distributed than
read speakers are instructing thousands
so that they will be able to protect
themselves and others from syphilis
anyone who thinks he has syphilis should
go at once to a physician because only a
physician can diagnose syphilis early
symptoms are sometimes so slight that
they may pass unnoticed the disease
develops insidiously years sometimes
elapse before it makes itself known the
knowledge of the patient's history is
the first step in diagnosis then follows
a thorough physical examination if sores
are found as is often the case in early
syphilis a dark field microscope is used
to determine whether or not an essential
part of any examination for syphilis is
a blood test the doctor takes a sample
of the patients blood seals it in a
sterile tube and sends it to a
laboratory there the delicate and
complicated test is applied the results
are checked and then recorded on
individual cards only a physician can
interpret the results of the test when
syphilis is found treatment must begin
at once
early treatment is the patient's great
hope of recovery cases discovered in the
early stages can usually be made non
infectious and completely cured even in
neglected cases the disease can often be
arrested and suffering relieved modern
treatment usually consists of injections
of some form of are synonyms and bismuth
which can be taken without interfering
with the patient's daily work treatments
must be taken regularly and persistently
injections over a period of a year or
longer may be required for permanent
results the patients must also follow
the doctor's orders as to food proper
rest and particularly his precautions
for protecting the health of others for
syphilis is a catching disease
especially in its early stage
transmitted nearly always by close body
contact it spreads from man to woman
from woman to man from husband to wife
and often from mother to unborn child as
it claims its million victims a year
since any syphilis infection is always
linked to one or more others doctor and
patients must cooperate to bring under
medical care the person who is spreading
infections for treatment makes syphilis
non-infectious the treatment of a single
case may prevent the suffering
disability and perhaps the death of no
one knows how many others
with a medical profession as the
spearhead of the attack the fight
against syphilis is well the guns
physicians are more alert than ever to
discover and treat infections in all
persons under their care free clinics
hospitals and health department's
provide medical care for those who can
afford to pay only small fees or nothing
at all health agencies contributes by
helping to trace infections and by
teaching syphilis victims how to prevent
the spread of infection many states now
require that every expectant mother be
examined and her blood tested for
syphilis a most important step for it is
one of the miracles of Medicine that
modern treatment prevents the
transmission of syphilis from mother to
unborn child an increasing number of
states require that before marriage both
bride and groom have an examination
including a blood test for syphilis and
similar laws are being pushed in other
states for government is found that
millions now spend for the support of
institutions for victims of syphilis can
be saved
industry too is beginning to realize
that war against syphilis is
tremendously important compensation cost
costly accident and labour turnover
often chargeable to syphilis can be
reduced and so many industries are
encouraging infected employees to secure
treatment but the work is only the gun
there is much to do government and
citizens have a tremendous task ahead
schools have a responsibility to teach
you the ways of health for 75% of all
syphilis is contracted before the age of
30 churches can do much by instilling
high ideals parents can guide the
protect and instruct growing children
communities can provide facilities for
wholesome play and community schools
must enforce laws which protect him from
degrading conditions
yes there is much to be done but thanks
to medical science thanks to research
workers physicians and public health
leaders all of the weapons for a
successful war against syphilis are at
hand syphilis can be diagnosed it can be
made non-infectious it can be cured only
one more thing is needed to defeat the
germs of syphilis knowledge of the facts
by every man and woman with widespread
knowledge and with these weapons America
can conquer syphilis in one generation